it is insane to me that people in 2015
still think they can own a hashtag
hashtag culture is very very important
specifically to Instagram and Twitter
and what I'm really talking about is how
the utility of a hashtag is actually
getting executed look I use hashtag ask
Gary Vee but I'm really just using that
for fans that are looking to go down the
rabbit hole more than getting it away
for awareness Saban if you want to go
right right now like school Gary Vee
hashtag a scary me I've lost ownership
of it I'll walk into tons of meetings
when the brands like let's own the
hashtag get them we're gonna own hashtag
Spring Fever and I'm like the hell are
you talking about no you're not hashtags
are not ownable
I mean that is what I'm pissed off about
like that's why we're making this video
I'm just trying to help people to
understand when you pick a hashtag
anybody in the world can jump into it
any hashtag you can create tomorrow I
can jump in and make a hashtag and as
often times as we've seen in marketing
change that conversation and make you
look stupid and when skittles put out
that hashtag and then people started
putting things that were very crude
against it because skittles homepage was
a filter and a stream of everybody using
the hash tagging and all of a sudden you
know body parts and rude and crude
things started showing up on their other
corporate page because there is no own
ability around a hashtag if we googled
right now we can find a hundred mishaps
but you know we've seen this happen with
McDonald's and skittles and Entenmann's
like it's just a it's just a lack of
understanding how Twitter works look at
the hashtags that are trending and very
popular on the two main platforms
already and try to figure out how to
reverse into them by putting out your
piece of content storytelling and then
using three or four hashtags that are
riding the wave and I wrote about this a
million years ago riding the wave of a
hashtag
don't try to establish one ride the wave
of four or five that are working that
are tie in and be creative into what
you're putting out